as a tragedy unfolded on the english
channel for the first time we're hearing
the mayday call that went out not long
before 27 people were confirmed to have
died
overboard approximately 15 man overboard
all ships in this area are requested to
have a short workout to proceed to this
area to take contact and report any
information to premiere mscc
as on so many other days hundreds of
people set off from the french beaches
yesterday in an array of boats some were
seaworthy others were not
this was a picture given to sky news by
a lifeboat captain it's believed to be
the boat that was taking those that lost
their lives
one of the first to reach the scene was
lifeboatman charles devos
it was really dramatic there were
floating bodies it was really very
shocking we recovered all the people we
saw and bought we recovered six people
all dead
yes
[Music]
there was one woman who said he was
pregnant in a young man 18 to 20 years
old and the rest were men
it is less than a day since 27 people
died trying to make it to britain
in dover this morning moore arrived
relieved that theirs was a safe crossing
and it is a tragedy that has refocused
politics for a french president not far
off an election
we are going to ask for extra help from
the british because all these men and
these women don't want to stay in france
we tell them they're able to do so and
there are centers in calais in dunkirk
where they can go
and it was a message echoed by the home
secretary pretty patel too
i've once again reached out and made my
offer very clear
to france in terms of joint france and
uk cooperation joint patrols to prevent
these dangerous journeys from taking
place i've offered to work with france
to put more officers on the ground
what happened yesterday was a dreadful
shock it was not a surprise but it is
also a reminder of how vulnerable people
are
put at peril when in the hands of
criminal gangs
and britain has long claimed that french
should do more to stop these boats
leaving last month we filmed these
people running down the beach near
calais with their boat heading for the
uk watched by french police who didn't
intervene
relations between britain and france
have been strained one side blames the
other for channel crossings and both
here in calais and on the other side of
the channel in kent authorities warned
that something like this could happen
but yesterday emmanuel macron and boris
johnson spoke and said that they would
both urgently step up action and that
all options remain on the table
this was dungeness this morning the
boats that did make it across the
channel taking people prepared to pay
thousands to smugglers and accept great
risks
risks that for too many have now come
horribly true
ali fordescu sky news in calais